Third, the large scale climate changes
that come from the concentrations
of greenhouse gases.
Here, for example, is how global
average surface temperatures
have changed over the last century.
The temperature record
is much less smooth
than the CO2 concentration record.
You see warming till about 1940,
then little change for a few decades.
Then warming that starts
again in the late '70s,
slowing down over the last decade.
Why?
Why does the temperature record looks
so bumpy when the CO2 concentration
record that drives it looks so smooth?
There are several reasons why
the records look so different.
First, because many factors push
the climate one way or another.
A big volcano, for example,
puts sulfuric acid drops
in the stratosphere that can cool
the whole planet for a year or two.
The same fossil fuels that
put carbon in the atmosphere
also pump out sulfur pollution
and other fine particulates.
These pollutants stay in the
atmosphere for only a few weeks,
but they can change the climate by
reflecting more sunlight back to space.
But unlike CO2 that accumulates slowly
and spreads evenly across the globe,
these pollutants have varied from
decade to decade and place to place,
as countries have changed the fuel
they use, perhaps from coal to gas,
and the environmental cleanup
technologies they use,
putting scrubbers on power plants
or catalytic converters on cars.
Second, the climate has lots
of natural fluctuations,
like the day to day
variability of weather,
that are random internal
dynamics of the climate system.
What physicists like
me like to call noise.
The net result is that we
can be reasonably confident
that much of the warming over the past
half century is due to human actions.
And very confident that
over the next century we
will see a great deal of
warming, due to human action.
But it's still very hard,
or outright impossible,
to know exactly what the climate
will do from one decade to the next.
This brings us to our fourth
component, climate impacts.
The many ways in which these
large-scale climate changes
influence human welfare
and the natural world.
Many important crops, such as rice or
wheat, are damaged by high temperatures
during the germination phase
of their growing season.
There's evidence that
temperature changes we've already
seen from global warming are cutting
global crop productivity, perhaps
by as much as 5%, compared
to what it would have
been had temperatures not increased.
Although the overall crop
productivity has continued to rise,
as agricultural methods have improved.
This is small, as a global
average, but by 2050, the impacts
will likely be much worse.
If we do not restrain carbon
emissions and climate change
over the next century,
warming will accelerate,
the melting of the great ice
sheets in Greenland and Antarctica,
raising global sea levels.
If we do not restrain emissions,
sea levels might rise by a meter
by the end of the century, and several
meters over the next few centuries.
Climate change is not just warming.
It tends to make the dry places
dryer, and the wet places wetter.
It increases the intensity
of the most intense storms.
It will create a host of other
changes, small and large,
from a dramatic decrease in
the amount of Arctic sea ice,
to a loss of coral reefs
driven by the acidifying
effects of CO2 in ocean waters.
This, and all other predictions, are
subject to significant uncertainty.
For example, with unrestrained
emissions, by the end of this century
sea level will likely rise anywhere
from half a meter to a meter.
But there's a good chance, perhaps
50% odds, that the rise will
be outside that range.
Many impacts, like rising sea
levels, occur far in the future.
Sea level rise is relatively
small this century, for example,
but it gets much bigger the next
century if we can't stop it.